HASHTAGS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> YES!
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, SO NICK
CANNON INSTAGRAMED THIS PHOTO OF
HIMSELF IN WHITE FACE.
I MEAN, HAVEN'T WHITE PEOPLE
TAKEN ENOUGH ABUSE?
NO, WE HAVEN'T.
IN ANY CASE, THIS PHOTO WAS TO
PROMOTE HIS UPCOMING ALBUM
"WHITE PEOPLE PARTY MUSIC" AND
IT FEATURED-- THIS IS ACTUALLY
THE MOST CRIMINAL PART OF THIS--
NINE HASHTAGS, NINE HASHTAGS.
BUT OF THOSE NINE HASHTAGS, THEY
WERE ALL STEREOTYPICAL WHITE BRO
THINGS SUCH AS #GOODCREDIT,
#FARMERSMARKET,
#CREAMCHEESEEATING.
SO COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU
GUYS TO COME UP WITH POSSIBLY
BETTER WHITE PEOPLE HASHTAGS
THAN NICK CANNON DID.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK, AND GO.
YES, ELIZA.
>> #GIRLSHBO.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
POINTS.
HANNIBAL.
>> #SKIBOOTS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
KAMAU.
>> #THIS BLACK NEIGHBORHOOD HAS
TOO MANY BLACK PEOPLE IN IT.
>> Chris: POINTS.
"YEAH, BUT I'M REALLY ARTY,
SO I WANT TO..."
HANNIBAL.
>> #I JUST GOT MY MASTERS
IN ANTHROPOLOGY.
(LAUGHTER0
>> Chris: POINTS.
KAMAU.
>> #AMC SUNDAY NIGHTS FOREVER!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: UM, YEAH!
(BLEEP) YEAH, AMC SUNDAY NIGHTS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
SOMEBODY'S GOT TO PAY FOR THIS
MOTHER(BLEEP)'S JAGUAR.
WHICH ALSO WOULD BE A WHITE
PERSON HASHTAG.
NEXT, NEXT.
YES, HANNIBAL.
>> #IRON AND WINE IS THE BEST
BAND TO EVER LIVE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
KAMAU.
>> #@MIDNIGHT'S WRITER'S ROOM.
>> Chris: WHAT?
(LAUGHTER)
UM...
YOU KNOW...
POINTS FOR CALLING US OUT!
DAMN IT!
>> #VOLVOLEASE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: ELIZA.
>> #WAYNEBRADY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
HANNIBAL.
>> #MONTESSORI SCHOOL.
(LAUGHTER)